the furniture giant IKEA is recalling
about seventeen point three million
chests and dressers after an eighth
child was killed by one of its products
the recall involves mom and other chests
and dressers like he admits they are
unstable and can tip over if not
properly anchored to the wall Don Dahler
shows us how children have been harmed
by the recalled furniture Don good
morning good morning the Dudek family
says their toddler had just gone down
for a nap but less than an hour later
they lived every parent's nightmare
their young son was pinned under his
bedrooms three drawer dresser and as
something their attorney says should
never have happened
Joseph Dudek is the latest victim
crushed under the weight of an Ikea mom
dresser in May this year his parents say
they had no idea their two-year-olds
bedroom furniture posed a deadly risk or
that it had been recalled nearly a year
earlier in 2016 IKEA recalled mom and
other model dressers after they caused
the deaths of seven other children
including 22 month old Ted McGee Camden
Ellis and Kern Collis both two years old
Allen Feldman represents the victims
families there was no reason to make
dressers which ikea knew had a tendency
to tip over the Consumer Product Safety
Commission says IKEA has received a
hundred and eighty six reports of
incidents with mom style chests and
dressers tipping and more than 90
children have been injured from them
these dressers are used in children's
bedrooms that's predominantly where
they're located children should be safe
in their own bedrooms in a statement the
swedish company says they have done
extensive outreach to communicate the
recall to more than 13 million consumers
however there is still more work to be
done
Feldman says the dudx never received
those notifications and believe IKEA
failed these families IKEA should devote
the same energy the same money and the
same time to the recall of this product
that they devoted to selling the product
according to the CPSC a child is injured
every 30 minutes in the United States
from a TV or furniture tip over incident
60% of tip-over fatalities involve
children between the ages of 2 & 5 IKEA
is urging parents to
Anker their dressers to the wall as is
cps a Director of Communications Joseph
Marty ik it takes very little time it
takes very little money but it's an
effort that is tremendous as far as
saving lives or injuries to your loved
ones customers can also request a refund
if they purchased a chest or dresser
doors involved in the recall IKEA still
sells the dressers albeit with a clear
warning about the tipping risk really
it's important to read the instructions
it it is and it can't be overstated that
these anchor kids on any piece of
furniture not just IKEA can save lives
if anything can tip top over with a
toddler it should really be anchored to
the wall and twelvers like to climb they
do yeah everything's an obstacle course
for them unfortunate that eight had to
lose their lives John thank you